on Monday actor Chris Hemsworth better
known as Thor explained the role of
James Bond should be redone this time
with Charlize Theron playing the part
sir on is the star of the
soon-to-be-released atomic blonde a bond
Jason Bourne female knockoff she
embodies every ounce of strength and
nobility and dignity and integrity the
character should have Hemsworth
explained she's smart as hell she's
physically able you know watching her in
those fight teams and Snow White and the
Huntsman doing it in high heels by the
whale an eight-foot-long gown was even
more impressive and I just think why not
it's time this is to put it mildly the
stupidest crap I have ever heard but it
is not rare to hear Hollywood Knights
virtue signaling by talking about their
ideal bond Ian McKellen said years ago
he'd like a gay bond but bond and bond
he has a character he's an ultra
straight womanizer from filling teenage
boy fantasies that is the entire point
of the character it just doesn't work
the same way with a woman bond is a bad
boy because he can seduce any woman no
matter how unavailable or beautiful
making bond a woman changes that
calculus utterly because virtually any
mildly attractive woman can do the same
with virtually any man it is not a
challenge for Charlize Theron to get a
man in bed as Amy Schumer has said I'm
160 pounds and I can catch a bleep
whenever I want
she is scientifically accurate as David
Schmidt PhD writes in Psychology Today
quote over the last few decades almost
all research studies have found that men
are much more Eagle Eagle for casual sex
than women are Oliver and Hyde 1993
Peterson in hi 2010 this is especially
true when it comes to desires for
short-term mating with many different
sexual partners and it's even more true
for wanting to have sex with complete
and total strangers in a classic social
experiment from the 1980s Clark and
Hatfield put the idea of sex differences
in consenting to sex with strangers to a
real-life test they had experimental
Confederates approach college students
around various campuses and asked quote
I've been noticing you around campus I
find you to be very attractive would you
like to go to bed to meet with me with
me tonight around seventy five percent
of men agreed to have sex with a
complete stranger
whereas zero women zero percent agreed
in terms of effect size this is one of
the largest sex differences ever
discovered in Psychological Science okay
folks this is not sexism it is science
furthermore there is always going to be
a necessary suspension of disbelief
while watching Charlize Theron who might
be 120 pounds soaking wet beat up guys
twice your size watching Daniel Craig
who's probably
and seventy do the same isn't quite the
same thing there are plenty of great
female action parts Tehran might well
play one anatomic blonde but hijacking
classic characters and having them
switch genders and or sexuality destroys
the characters there's a decent case for
Idris Elba's bond color doesn't change
the map for bonds character there is no
case further on or any other woman to be
James Bond just stop it you're being an
idiot I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
[Music]
all righty so I mean just do anything
things can't get any stupider they get
stupid or really like this it's funny
what what dragon devil well this sort of
stuff drives me totally up a law like
the idea you're just going to turn James
Bond into woman nothing changes because
men and women are different stupid
people
stupid stupid leftist men and women are
totally different before we get to all
of the breakdown from from Trump care
and the fallout and who's to blame and
is Trump kind of pay and price or is
Congress going to play a price we'll
talk about all of those things plus and
want to get to Jake Tapper taking on
Linda Sarsour which is really quite
wonderful we'll get to all of those
things and I'll give you the update by
the way on a prospective intern that we
will be interviewing hopefully in the
next 48 hours but before we do any of
that I want to I want to say thank you
to our sponsors over at different with
zip recruiter if you want to get interns
not by actually actively soliciting the
children of crazy feminists but actually
by getting just the best employee who is
available then zip recruiter you can
post your jobs to 100 plus job sites
with just one click and then they're
powerful technology efficiently matches
the right people to do your job better
than anyone else
zip recruiter is different it doesn't
depend on candidates finding you it
finds them 80% of jobs zip recruit or
get a qualified candidate in just 24
hours we use zip recruiter here at the
show find out why zip recruiter has been
used by businesses all over the country
to find the most qualified job
candidates and right now if you go to
zip recruiter comm for free and you use
slash daily wired zip recruiter comm
slash daily wire for free you can post
jobs right now zip recruiter comm slash
daily wire once more to try it out for
free zip recruiter comm slash daily why
that's the best way to find the best
candidates for your job if only we had
done that with our own employees
originally but now we're stuck with them
and can't fire the Mathis so in any case
zip recruiter comm slash daily wire make
sure they know that we sent you okay so
we actually love Mathis we just make fun
of him because he's in the room if
Austin were in the room which he no
longer is and we'd make fun of him as
well in any case you have to be within
my actual visual spectrum in order for
me to mock you Jonathan in any case they
medicate I met it will give you the
quick update on unfeminist son intern
because that was making some news last
night so as you recall last Friday I
talked about this lady named Jodi Allard
Jodi Allard wrote a piece in The
Washington Post
and then she wrote a follow-up piece at
some no-name website where she talked
about how her sons were potential
rapists because they had the penis and
that means that if you have such a thing
this means the you are potential rapists
according to Jodi Ehlert so I said that
I would offer her son an internship to
help him escape the clutches of evil mom
and last night an independent journalist
named up artist Ella who used to work
over at Daily wire she's a story about
the check she contacted Jodi Allard son
and found out that he was interested in
the in national internship with us and
so he sends her resume to her she
forwarded on to us last night Jodi
Allard obviously out of Lube tweeted at
me and said is this internship stunt
just two stunts we haven't heard
anything from you to which I replied
well obviously you don't talk to your
son who you call a prospective rapist
all that much because he sent us a
resume and I have it right here on my
desk so hopefully we'll be talking to to
Jared which is the name of her son
sometime in the next 24-48 hours were
seems we can work out that phone call
right now we'd love to work something
out with him obviously the skill set has
to match but if it's even a remote match
we'll find some way to work with him
because anything to to get some money so
that he can escape that house because
horrifying horrifying okay so that is
via assess particular story in other
news the the Trump carrot bill went down
yesterday it went down because Mike Lee
and Jerry Moran from Kansas and the
enthusing Collins from Maine and Rand
Paul all said they were not going to
vote for it and that means that a bunch
of people on the right are now blaming
these folks for the collapse now it's
fair to blame Susan Collins because
Susan Collins is never going to vote for
any sort of Obamacare appeal she likes
Obamacare it is not fair to blame Mike
Lee or Rand Paul Rand Paul there's been
suggestion that Rand Paul never votes
for things because that's just a shtick
even that is quasi fair but it is not
fair to blame Mike Lee the reason that
it is not fair to blame Mike Lee is
because there are a bunch of people
today who are saying that Michael Lee
preserved Obamacare britt hume says this
you hewitt says this that the obamacare
has been preserved by Mike Lee and Rand
Paul this is a bunch of crap Obamacare
was preserved by the bill itself
the bill itself kept all of the
regulations under Obamacare it added
some subsidies and got rid of some of
the taxes and a restructure Medicaid now
if the Republicans had come along I've
been saying this legitimately for months
if the Republicans had come along to
listen we're just going to fix Obamacare
for the time being we're going to try
and fix it and make some changes that
move us in the right direction but it's
not full Obamacare repeal we are
gradually going to get to full Obamacare
repeal then I would have signed on to
this bill in all likelihood and I think
probably so would Mike Lee but by
calling it Obamacare repeal and replace
the implication is that this was the
last step so when people say that
Obamacare was going to be repealed
except for Mike Lee that's just nonsense
it is just not true it is fully
dishonest when people say that don't
look to Mike Lee as the the cause of the
collapse here there there are many
causes of the collapse here but the
first and foremost one is that
Republicans rely okay they didn't
actually want to get rid of Obamacare
they just didn't okay and it's the
constituents didn't President Trump
didn't President Trump was one who
insisted back in January by the way that
we not do full-scale repeal instead we
do repeal and replace that was Trump's
suggestion and then he walked away from
that when it turned out that people
couldn't agree on what the replacement
would look like and actually didn't want
to do full-scale repeal so Trump was out
there trying to claim this as a victory
yesterday even though it was a loss this
is what Trump does best
he likes to spin and and the fact is
that here is president from yesterday
talking about how it was really a
victory like if you wouldn't know any
better than it was totally a victory we
have 52 people we had four knows now we
might have had another one somewhere in
there but essentially the vote would
have been pretty close to if you look at
it forty eight to four that's a pretty
impressive vote by any standard and yet
you have a vote of 48 to 4 or something
like that and you need more it's pretty
tough we have 52 people okay that is not
impressive by any standard the standard
is passing things it is like Hillary
Clinton won the popular vote okay so you
got 48 out of 52 first of all not even
clear there were 48 out of 52 it's just
clear that four would not vote for it
not that 48 would but you can't spend
this as a victory when it is not a
victory and as I said yesterday there
was a vacuum of leadership from the top
Trump doesn't know what's in this bill
he doesn't really care what's in this
bill he didn't use the bully pulpit in
any way he didn't threaten moderates to
get on board he didn't threaten
conservatives to get on board he thinks
that his Twitter basically alleviates
him of the necessity of learning things
and so he can just sweet things out and
that will fix it
that is not correct today he's supposed
to have a bunch of senators to the White
House where he's going to talk to them
about these things we'll see if that
moves the ball at all
but unless he is actually actively going
to use the power that he has to threaten
senators who refuse to go along with him
then he's not doing anything he's not as
I said yesterday the only power that
Trump has over these senators because
his approval ratings in that high is
that his approval rating among
Republicans is still sky-high it's still
82% among Republicans that means he has
the capacity to threaten them with
funding cuts his the capacity to
threaten them with primary challengers
he hasn't done any of those things yet
he's sort of sitting back and letting it
happen and the reason he's sitting back
and letting it happen is because he
thinks that and it's an interesting
strategy he thinks that if he just says
that he's gonna let Obamacare fail then
all will be well
Obama care will collapse and then he
will be there to pick up the pieces
people will blame Democrats not
Republicans this was his self stated
strategy and he said this openly
yesterday and I think you'll also agree
that I've been saying for a long time
let Obamacare fail and then everybody's
going to have to come together and fix
it and come up with a new plan and a
plan that's really good for the people
with much lower premiums not much lower
cost and much better protection I've
been saying that Mike I think you'll
agree for a long time let Obamacare fail
it'll be a lot easier and I think we're
probably in that position where we'll
just let Obamacare fail we're not going
to own it
I'm not going to own it I can tell you
the Republicans are not going to own it
will let Obamacare fail and then the
Democrats are going to come to us and
they're going to say how do we fix it
how do we fix it or how do we come up
with a new plan okay this had been his
original strategy then it might have
worked but it's kind of funny to watch
Mike Pence in these clips because he's
awkwardly nodding even though he
disagrees like yesterday Mike Pence said
we still have to repeal so he's
obviously disagree with President Trump
but that's not his job right his job is
to sort of be a yes-man for Trump in any
case Trump saying let Obamacare fail
there this would be a fine strategy if
he had come out of the gate muted listen
Obamacare is failing we have a problem
here the only way this is getting solved
is with a bipartisan solution so I want
a call to the White House Chuck Schumer
and Mitch McConnell and Nancy Pelosi and
Paul Ryan and I want to have a series of
meetings to set up a framework for AB
Hardison fix on Obamacare and then when
things collapse you say oh look at those
Democrats they wouldn't work with us
there was nothing we could do but that's
not what Trump actually did right what
Trump did is he went to his Republicans
and he said we're going to repeal the
whole thing that didn't happen anything
we're going to repeal in a place the
whole thing that isn't happening so now
it looks like he's just making excuses
and blaming Democrats that's actually
what it looks like okay it's again
there's a way to do this where you
didn't actually put your handprint on
Obamacare it's sort of here's the
situation the sort is in the stone right
and the Obamacare sort is in the stone
that is the status quo the sword is in
the stone the way to there are two
things you could do about that you could
either look at the Democrats and points
at them and say listen the sword is in
the stone it shouldn't be in the stone
you're the ones who put it there and I
know and you know that unless we
cooperate we can't get the sword out of
the stone or you could do a trump and
the Republicans did and say if you elect
us we will remove the sword from the
stone and then they don't remove the
sword from the stone and then they say
well the sword is only in the stone
because the Democrats put it there
anyway okay that doesn't have the same
appeal it doesn't have the same appeal
and it's a bit of a mistake because
Democrats are jumping on this to say
okay well now he acknowledges that
Obamacare is failing he acknowledges
that the health care system has problems
and he's not going to fix it in fact
he's going to make it worse so if it
were Democrats in there if you elected
us we'd fix the thing right we wouldn't
get rid of it we'd fix the thing it is
what Democrats are going to claim if you
had elected us if you'd made us if you
made Hillary the president you'd may put
us in Congress we would have fixed the
thing we would have removed the sword
from the stone our selves but you
elected Trump instead and so he's just
going to and complain about what
exactly the white why the stones the
sword is there in the first place so
Trump is continuing to make this case he
says you know we need to elect more
republicans that's the goal here just
elect more republicans so the way I look
at it is in 18 we're going to have to
get some more people elected we have to
go out and we have to get more people
elected than a Republican and we have to
probably pull in those people those few
people that voted against it I don't
know they're going to have to explain to
you why they did and I'm sure they'll
have very fine reasons but we have to
get more Republicans elected because we
have to get it done we got it passed in
the house we would have gotten it very
much yeah you can use his head as they
stand right we don't want that to happen
you messed with the wrong guy here so we
want we want I think we're going to do
very well actually in 18 I would be not
surprised if something were done long
before that but in any event because the
margin is so small the majority margin
says well we're going to have to go out
and get more Republicans elected in 18
and I'll be working very hard for that
to happen okay okay so this has been the
consistent Republican pitch for years
right give us the house will repeal
Obamacare give us the Senate will repeal
Obamacare give us the presidency will
repeal Obamacare I don't know how much
longer you can run this scam when you
run the majority in both houses and
you're still not repealing Obamacare and
have no intention of passing a full
repeal Mitch McConnell is supposedly
going to put the full repeal to a vote
on Monday now understand something even
the full repeal bill right the plain
simple repeal bill doesn't actually
repeal Obamacare because the regulations
are still included it gets rid of the
subsidies it gets rid of the taxes but
it doesn't actually get rid of the
Obamacare regulations what you're going
to require some actual legislation
separate legislation to get rid of the
Obamacare regulations under the
reconciliation rules do Republicans need
more people in the Senate yes and now
would be a great time to put more
Republicans in the Senate
considering that you've got I think 10
Democratic seats in red state that are
up in this next election cycle so if
Republicans were to pick up even four of
those then they'd have a really solid
majority going into the second half of
trumps term but he is going to need to
do a better job of making the case again
if you're gonna put blame on Democrats
you have to explain why the blame is on
Democrats yesterday Sarah Huckabee Smith
as Huckabee Sanders rather she came out
and she said that that it was Democrats
fault that it was that this had all
happened it's hard to make the case it's
Democrats fault when you never reached
out to Democrats in the first place so
this is a botch basically from the
beginning and I'm not sure that Trump is
going to get out of it that easily now
is it going to hurt Trump I don't know
hurt Trump I think it'll hurt Congress
so if you look at the generic
congressional ballot right now generic
congressional ballot has Democrats up
ten that is wipeout territory for
Republicans if the Democrats are up ten
then Republicans if that were real right
Democrats would win probably back the
majority in the house unclear what
happened in the Senate Kissena traces
are different but they'd be in good
shape to win back the majority in the
house there's one poll statistic that's
great for Trump in this which says that
the 20% of Republic
most enamoured of Trump are highly
likely to vote more likely to vote than
20% of Democrats who really hate Trump
the question is about the lukewarm
Republicans the lukewarm revival and
what do those lukewarm Republicans think
about all this are they feeling good
right now are they feeling enthused
right now so I think what you're going
to see is President Trump go back to
bashing the media because if legislation
is hard bashing the media is easy he can
do a unilaterally ginza by himself the
base loves it he's going to run against
the media in 2018 even if there is
nothing else for him to run on meanwhile
the Democrats are going to say listen
Republicans refuse to even make basic
fixes there's talk that Trump is going
to remove some of the subsidies for the
Obamacare exchanges and exacerbate the
death spiral in order to bring Democrats
to the table Democrats are saying well
that's mean and that's cruel so their
case is going to be listen we all know
the things flawed but only one party
here wants to actually fix it and it's
not the Republicans who won't even
repeal and replace that's exactly what
Bernie Sanders is saying saying Trump
wants millions of people to suffer well
by responses last I heard Trump was the
President of the United States the
leader of our country Republicans
controlled the House and the Senate and
it is beyond comprehension all I know
it's you know we keep saying this about
Donald Trump but it is beyond
comprehension that you have a president
who basically wants millions of people
to suffer so he thinks that he can win
some political points the problem is
that what Trump is saying runs directly
into the teeth of this okay when when
Trump says let Obamacare fail and then
Democrat and then Sanders opposes one
piece times when Obama can fail
what he means is he wants millions of
people to die right when he says that it
has a little more credibility than it
normally would because he's not offering
any alternative right and this is this
is the big problem here Chuck Schumer
says the same thing he says the
Republican plan is going to kill the
patient
obviously this exaggerated language
obviously he's wrong obviously he's
lying it's amazing if the Republicans
had just repealed this thing we'd go
back to status quo ante which was know
Obamacare when 92% of Americans had
health insurance I think so the fact is
that the vast majority of Americans
always had health insurance it's not
that Obamacare saved millions of people
or anything but that's the case Schumer
is trying to make in fact passing repeal
and having it go into effect two years
later is in many ways worse
than the Republican healthcare bill that
was just rejected by my Republican
colleagues it's like if our health care
system was a patient who came in and
needed some medicine the Republicans
proposed surgery the operation was a
failure now Republicans are proposing a
second surgery that will surely kill the
patient
medicine is needed bipartisan medicine
not a second surgery okay and this is
why I was important to have a clear
strategy going and not because humor is
anything but a liar he is an absolute
liar as evidence into deduction was a
liar yesterday he tweeted out that
anti-zionism is anti-semitism this is a
guy who endorsed for the leadership of
the Democratic National Committee keith
ellison a devotee of louis farrakhan who
has said multiple anti-semitic things in
the past and hung out with with
anti-semites you know Chuck Schumer is a
pathological liar on politics but this
is a game and you have to know how to
play the game and the Democrats right
now are out playing the Republicans even
from a minority position it is amazing
to watch how incompetent the Republicans
are about all of this well before we get
to the the more news about Trump there's
there's some polls out that show how
Trump is going to run in 2020 and we'll
talk about that in just a second but
before we get to that I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at
stamps.com
so if you're tired of waiting in line at
the post office you just don't have time
to go over there and wait for the stamps
and get your mail wait you just want to
do it straight from the office you
didn't go over to the grocery store you
don't have stamps what do you do you go
over to stamps calm you can print the
stamps out directly onto a piece of
paper tape it to your envelope directly
onto the envelope you can print it onto
a sticker and they will send you right
now over at stamps com if you use the
promo code Shapira go to the microphone
at the top of the homepage and type in
Shapiro then they will send you a
digital scale so you can even weigh your
mail and know exactly how much it's
going to cost to send things they will
send you it's a four week trial free
plus postage and the digital scale with
no long term commitments when you go to
stamps com promo code Shapiro never go
to the post office again even if you
like the post office you don't want to
spend time there so go over to stamps
comm and use that promo code Shapiro
when you click on the microphone at the
top of the page it'll automatically
calculate again they send you that for
with trial plus postage digital scale no
long-term
great service make sure that you check
it out and use that primal country pero
so that they know that we sent you okay
so with the Democrats claiming that
Republicans are waiting in the wings to
murder people you would think that the
that not only would the Republicans be
in trouble in Congress they'd be in
trouble in the presidential polls and
indeed if you look at the latest poll
from Public Policy Polling yes it's a
democratic polling firm and yes the
polls don't mean a lot when they're far
out but it's kind of interesting to look
at it the the fact is that right now
if Trump ran against most of the major
Democratic candidates he would lose so
they talked to 836 registered voters
they said that that majority wish that
Obama were president versus Trump and
already wished that Hillary would
present instead of Trump although she
has worse approval ratings than Trump
does but though the ones that matter
that against Joe Biden in a hypothetical
matchup against Joe Biden he would
supposedly lose 54 to 39 against Bernie
Sanders 52 to 39 so before everybody
says well polling is just terrible
polling is always wrong the polling at
the national polling had the state
polling was off in the last election
cycle the national poll er was not off
the national polling was on so before
you do before you say to me all polls
are worthless it is not good when the
current presidents of the United States
is in for you know he's only been in for
six months this should be the high point
of his term he's already losing to Joe
Biden and Bernie Sanders combined age
2309 by double digits he's apparently
losing in a hypothetical contest of
Elizabeth Warren that one I don't
believe cory booker 45:40 Kamala Harris
forty one forty now this should be a tip
to Democrats this is what's truly
fascinating about where the Democrats
are so I keep talking about the problems
Republicans are having which makes sense
since they're the governing party and
they're not good at it but the problems
the Democrats are having are so much
worse there's so much worse than the
problems Republicans are having yes
Republicans are bad at everything except
for increasing military spending and tax
cuts those are the only two things that
Republicans are good at because they
have no consensus on anything else but
the Democrats have not figured out what
exactly their party is about is their
party about big government socialism the
sort of cross-cultural socialism of Joe
Biden or Bernie Sanders or are they
still so in love with the men
Corie of barack obama they're going to
pursue intersectionality down to its
root look at those poll numbers again
this is what's fascinating not that
trump's going to lose to all these
people because you know it doesn't mean
anything we're we're too far out but
look at the contrast joe biden 54 bernie
sanders 52 warren 49 booker 45 Kamala
Harris 41 which one of those names has
been the hottest in the Democratic press
lately Kamala Harris right the senator
from California the first term senator
from California why not because she's
good at her job she's unbelievably
crappy at her job just like she was
unbelievably crappy of being Attorney
General in my state but why do they like
her because she is a black woman and
this means that she has checked two of
the intersectional boxes for people
don't understand what intersectionality
is basically intersectionality suggests
that all of American society was
designed to privilege white males and
that there is an intersectional
hierarchy of people who have been
victimized by American society whose
credibility cannot be challenged when
they talk about how America needs to
change so at the very top you have LGBT
folks and then you have black women and
then you have black men and then you
have Hispanic women and then you have
Hispanic men and then you have Asians
and then you have Jews and then finally
way down at the bottom you have white
males right that will most are Muslims
ranked somewhere between blacks and
LGBTQ folks so this is the
intersectional hierarchy the Democrats
have decided that it is more important
for them to cobble together a coalition
of the dispossessed right a coalition of
the angry then it is to actually come up
with a message that appeals to a broad
swath of Americans which is why they
ally with people like Linda Sarsour it's
why they push people like keith ellison
they've doubled down on identity
politics because they believe that the
demographics of the country are moving
in their direction and if they continue
to alienate white voters it won't make a
difference this failed them in 2016
because white voters white blue-collar
voters for the first time voted as a
racial bloc in almost racial bloc more
white blue-collar voters voted for
President Trump than Hispanics voted for
Hillary Clinton in the last election
cycle hey white voters voted as an
intersectional hierarchy group in
Reverse but Democrats are still doing
this and so when you look at the actual
be a hint to Democrats but they're too
stupid to ticket and when you look at
the the candidates who are most likely
to succeed against Trump is candidates
like Joe Biden a white male
Bernie Sanders a white male Elizabeth
Warren a white woman and then you go
down the list and you get two black man
Cory Booker
black woman Kamala Harris so precisely
the opposite of what the intersectional
hierarchy would suggest would be a
successful strategy is is what would
work and that's what Democrats are
rejecting Democrats are much more
interested than focusing in full scale
on which person can we pick who is going
to please minority communities even if
they have no broad-based appeal like
Kamala Harris pretty amazing stuff the
Democrats are not going to take that
advice and we're going to talk about
that in just a second but for that are
going to have to go over to Daley wire
so for those who don't know this is a
video show not just an audio show you
can watch the first 15 minutes live at
Facebook but if you want to watch the
entire thing live you have to go over to
Daley wire comm $9.99 a month gets you a
subscription it also gets you access to
our mail back so your answer your
questions shall be answered and your
life made better
it also means we get to view Andrew
Clayton's show live every day except for
product you get to be part of his
mailbag which I believe he's doing today
so you check that out over at Daly we're
calm you can even see the brand new
Michael Moser once that coming out
Monday and then the following Monday so
a week from Monday the Michael notes
show god help us we'll be premiering and
you'll be able to view that live over at
Daly wire.com if you want a full
subscription annual subscription you
also get the website ad free by the way
then you will it for 99 bucks a year for
an annual subscription you get this
magnificent unbelievable tremendous
unbelievable spectacular beautiful
beautiful mug okay this tumbler right
here that says upon it let's just here's
how to cope from the daily wire you will
enjoy knowing you're friends with it is
also really aminos is made of ceramic
it's really fantastic
so is dishwasher safe it is incredible
so you get that with an annual
subscription so go over to daily wire
comm right now and check it out or go
over to iTunes or SoundCloud later and
you can and you can listen to the show
make sure you leave us a review and
subscribe we always appreciate it we are
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
meanwhile while all this is going on you
know well the Democrats are struggling
to come up with an identity they keep
centering around people like Linda
Sarsour okay so yesterday I thought this
was just amazing the Democrats the
women's March we talked about this two
days ago the women's March had paid
tribute to Assata Shakur who's an actual
terrorist like an actual terrorist human
being who shot a cop in New Jersey back
in the 1970s in 279 and then fled to
Cuba they paid tribute to her and they
did this whole shtick about how they
don't believe in her violence but they
appreciate that she fought sexism within
the black within the Black Panther Party
which is like saying I don't appreciate
what a ton bin Laden does with American
buildings but I do appreciate him
fighting Islamophobia around the world
no no no but the women's March tweeted
that out so Jake Tapper who as I've said
before is one of the few people in the
media who I think actually tries to get
it right and I know there's a lot of
disagreement about Jake Tapper in on the
right but I think Jake is actually
attempting to be intellectually honest
is he still a guy of the left I think he
is but he's an intellectually honest
fellow or at least attempts to be and so
yesterday he tweeted this out Shakur is
a cop-killer fugitive in Cuba this ugly
sentiments from Linda Sarsour and the
Dyke March in Chicago you remember that
story it's where the the lesbian March
in Chicago banned Jews because they were
flying a flag that had a Jewish sign on
it made the intersectional hierarchy
uncomfortable he said any progressives
out there condemning this which is
exactly right and then Tsar sewer called
Jake Tapper a member of the of the
alt-right she said Jake Tapper please
share my ugly sentiments
unapologetically Muslim apologetically
Palestinian pro-immigrant Pro justice
shame okay so first of all whenever
people say shame they usually have no
real reason to do so that goes to Game
of Thrones as well and in any case Linda
Sarsour says what about me so bad and
Jake Tapper immediately slams or he says
your comments about ayaan Hirsi Ali from
one so if you recall she said about
ayaan Hirsi Ali who is a who is in a
Muslim who's no longer Muslim riichi
issues a heretic under Muslim law she
was generally mutilated by MS Lamas and
then they attempted to force her into a
child marriage she fled she ended up
in Denmark and and now she lives in the
United States I believe that she's nerd
sending all Ferguson the historian from
Harvard and and Linda Sarsour had said
that she wished she could remove ayaan
Hirsi Ali vagina so Jake Tapper's
calling her out on that and there's no
whole history I mean we've talked about
Linda Sarsour before Linda Sarsour is a
radical she is somebody who has spoken
highly of terrorists and terrorist
groups before she's really a
devastatingly bad human being and Jake
Tapper took her to the woodshed here
when even Jake Tapper is taking you to
the woodshed because you're so extreme
that should say something to the
Democratic Party but it doesn't because
the Democratic Party is so ensconced in
its own belief that all that matters is
building a coalition to take down
Western civilization that they don't
care who they include in that coalition
from Linda Sarsour to Assata Shakur none
of it matters you know cop killers
terrorist apologists none of it none of
it matters so the Democrats are still
having this trouble which means the only
unity they have is again as always being
anti Republicans so last night they went
nuts because apparently president Trump
had an undisclosed meeting with Vladimir
Putin there was a big meeting over at
the g20 there's a big dinner that was
held by the by by Angela Merkel over the
g20 and apparently during the dinner
President Trump who was not seated next
to Vladimir Putin but Melania was he got
up and he walked away from where he was
sitting he walked around to Vladimir
Putin pulled up a chair and proceeded to
have a full hour conversation with no
other American official present so I
didn't bring Rex Tillerson he didn't
bring a Russian translator the only
person who was there was Bouton's
translator which is not great because
you never know what if Putin translator
is telling Trump lies right Putin could
be saying look at this America look up
these American schmuck and then the
translator says he says you're a
wonderful guy or I mean they could
that's exactly what could be happening
plus you know Putin is old KGB this is
not if you are in Trump's cabinet the
last thing you want is a meeting where
you don't have anyone in there who's
able to at least monitor what's being
said we've had this problem before last
time Trump was in a room alone with
Russians he ended up spilling Israeli
national security information that put
in danger an Israeli spy who is trying
to spy on Isis so you have this meeting
and the media goes crazy oh this is
obviously something nefarious going on
now listen do I think that
when you have a meeting that's an hour
long at one of these things that we
should know what's happening yes because
I am for full-scale transparency from
any president and I don't think that
that's really appropriate I do want to
know from the media and I just don't
know the answer to this is it that Trump
has lots of meetings with the Russians
and then doesn't disclose it or is it
Trump has lots of meetings with everyone
and doesn't disclose it I mean I've seen
reports that he had meetings with with
various other governmental actors over
the last six months and then it was
reported like four days later but no one
cared because it wasn't Russia so it's
hard to tell how much of this is real
and how much of this is just the media
thinking that every time from eat
something with Russian dressing on it
he's spine with Vladimir Putin in any
case Putin continues to speak highly of
Trump here's what Vladimir Putin had to
say about him well most important he met
with Donald Trump recently this guy
could include pretty interesting to hear
your impression of him as a person on
you know coca-cola Rick Truman years ago
I did not expect this and I believe it
is very important for a person who has a
public profile on politicians when we
meet solutions he has the ability to
listen students which was really just
what our conversation wasn't a couple
times of you miss ubusuna I do not know
what he's like with other people he
talked to you but during our
conversation I listened to him with
attention as well formidable squirt
immediately when he set out his ideas
and proposals on development cooperation
and he didn't say but you know there was
something does not happen excuse me for
a person who works in people who's
involved in cultures I reiterate museum
vitally important ability you were to be
able to listen and respond and
communicate promptly that substantial
experience Emily who put there's a
position it's like pretty much uses like
you to Chicago to compare some people
only hear themselves whatever you will
tell them quote is like a buzz in the
background for them what was it when
you're talking about a thing it also use
them couple most notoriously if I've got
a Buckeyes what perfect
current US president is different he
responds what his interlocutor says when
the argument he responds them okay so in
other words Putin is trying to butter up
from that's the way that you do it this
is why you don't want to have these
meetings alone Trump tweeted out that
the media is making a big deal out of
all of this and I tend to believe that
Trump is correct about this he says fake
news story of secret dinner with Putin
is sick implication marks I mean he
might be right about this but he really
needs
learn how to use scare quotes that's not
how they work says all g20 leaders and
spouses were invited by the Chancellor
of Germany press new well to be fair the
press wasn't saying that the meeting
itself this dinner was secret they were
saying that he never disclosed that he
talked with Putin for an hour the White
House released a statement saying is a
brief meet and greet people in the room
say it was an hour so there's still
details to come out but the media is
going to continue jumping all over the
Russia thing and playing up every little
thing which means that Trump should be
careful here because you know if you
want to win then you might want to just
be careful about how you how you conduct
yourself there's no reason to give the
other side this much this much material
on a day-in day-out basis so final
conclusion here with regard to Obama
care and where it is going I don't think
that what happened with Obamacare is
going to damage from it is very obvious
that the Republican press are not
interested in going after Trump in any
way because the constituency for
Republicans is still much more enamored
of Trump than with Republican Congress
people by Republican Congress people are
still much more unpopular than Trump so
you're seeing an motivated attempt by
the media on the right to guard Trump
from the blowback that means that Trump
has the power to push something through
he doesn't have to I think what's more
likely to happen is Trump is likely to
continue shilly-shallying around not
really taking a solid position on Obama
care nothing gets past Republicans get
blamed in the Congress Trump separates
himself off and then he works with
Democrats I think that is the most
likely thing but you never know right
it's all unpredictable I do not know
that his strategy of let it all fail and
then Republicans won't pay for it is
going to work however okay we're going
to get some things I like and some
things I hate but first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at upside
comm so if you travel for business
upside dome is the best travel site that
you can find they bundle together your
flight and your hotel they give you all
sorts of options if you fly into a
different Airport if you go to a
different hotel if you come in at a
different time and they get you the most
inexpensive options available on the
market you will save money by bundling
those flight to end hotel together for
one price and then they also reward you
with the gift card to places like Amazon
every single time you buy a trip so you
get the the benefit your company gets
the benefit of the cheaper flight and
hotel and you get the benefit of the
Amazon gift card which comes directly
back to you it is the real deal try
upside calm when you use promo code Ben
you are guaranteed to get at least a
$100 Amazon
card for your first trip that is code
been to get a $100 gift card for free
with minimum purchase required you can
see the site for complete details they
are really just fantastic you can you
can get not only the cheapest and least
expensive thing and like I travel for
business all the time we use upside comm
and they get you the best options
available plus we get the the Amazon
gift cards which is pretty great so go
to up side calm and use that promo code
been for the guarantee use the promo
code band and you get a $100 gift card
Amazon your very first trip with minimum
purchase use that promo code bents that
they know that we sent you as well okay
time for some things I like and then
we'll do some things that I hate so
things that I like so Martin Landau died
this week which is really sad Martin
Landau is a really charming actor for
some reason I always just get him mixed
up with Leonard Nimoy but they're very
different actors Martin Landau is a much
more versatile actor than Leonard Nimoy
he was in a lot of stuff the thing that
I grew up with him in was Mission
Impossible when I was growing up my
parents used to rent for us old TV shows
they didn't actually let us watch a lot
of the Current TV because it was too
sexualized so they would go out and
they'd rent old episodes of The Waltons
we go down to Eddie Brandt Saturday
matinee which is the greatest video
store in human history we'd go over
there and we would get old they had like
full seasons of The Waltons and Mary
Tyler Moore and the Dick Van Dyke Show
so we grew up on all that TV and one of
the shows that I used to watch this also
show reruns of it so I used to get up
and watch them was a Mission Impossible
the original Mission Possible
which is much better than the movies so
a lot of people like the movies movies
have nothing to do with Mission
Impossible basically they kept the name
and then they have nothing like the
entire premise of Mission Impossible is
all these clever plots and most Mission
Impossible now is Tom Cruise which is
Jack Reacher which is Top Gun which is
you know Tom Cruise being an action star
and running around leaping off buildings
that was never the Mission Impossible
thing the Mission Impossible thing was
always you have a team that's working
and then very little of the jumping off
buildings action sequences is much more
driven by can they create a plot to
prevent something bad from happening
here at the original trailer music from
Mission Impossible you'll see Martin
Landau his shtick was that he was always
dressing up in somebody so every episode
he put on a wig or he'd put on like a
fake nose and then he would just take it
off ooh
Lando's rest up in something is it's
fantastic so here is the original
mission impossible
[Music]
there's one right there technology say
right
[Music]
[Applause]
Peter Graves was the original star
tonight
[Music]
beautiful barber vain horse it's a great
trip so didn't go watching the old
episode it's really really good he he
also had a long career in Hollywood he
did a lot of pretty good movies he made
his first major film parents you'll
remember in North by Northwest who was
the right-hand man of James Mason who is
the major criminal in that he was also
in Cleopatra and the greatest story ever
told and you'll remember that he was
also in rounders right so if you say if
you've seen rounders he's great in
rounders he's the the old law professor
who basically tells Matt Damon to pursue
his dream of being a loser gambler so
that's a he's great in that and he he's
in his later days he got less productive
obviously but he does have a star on the
Hollywood Walk of Fame a very very good
actor and sad to see him go okay so
other things that I like so this was
just hilarious yesterday Chris Christie
the rotund governor of New Jersey who
everyone hates at this point went to a
Mets game and if you're Chris Christie
probably the worst thing you can do
right now is go into a highly public
setting and a ball is hit and you'll see
Chris Christie catch it and watch what
the crowd does and a souvenir for Chris
Christie are you kidding me how about
that
you just noticed payments your
who are you HOT I'll tell you there's no
crowd for the winning what do you know I
you know get the ball left hannity hatch
and christie's reached out it kinda
actually pretty good catch my christmas
right already your daddy catches it nice
to see doesn't matter still gets booed
because he's chris christie which is
just epic so you got to love that about
the Mets crowd I am NOT the biggest fan
of New Yorkers as a general matter but
that is pretty spectacular so well done
New York Mets fans kind of love it okay
time for a couple of things that I hate
the first thing that I hate is late on
Monday the Trump administration
certified to Congress that Iran has been
meeting its necessary requirements under
the joint comprehensive plan of action
this would be Obama's Iran deal as you
recall President Trump promised the day
one he was going to pull out of the Iran
deal on the very first day he was going
to pull out of it it is still operative
and he has now twice certified that Iran
is in compliance the problem with that
is that the Iran deal specifically
allows them to continue operating
without sanctions it continues to allow
them to develop their centrifuges at a
certain rate it it requires them
supposedly to reduce the number of
functional centrifuges used to enrich
uranium and forfeit uranium stockpiles
but they say that they say that that
Iran is violating the spirit of the
agreement but they're not violating the
text of the agreement and then you have
the State Department saying that Iran
remains one of the most dangerous
threats to US interests okay if that's
the case then just reject the stupid
deal just reject the stupid deal in last
April Obama with Trump was landing the
Obama deal as disastrous he said in
front of a packed it was catastrophic
hey either kill the deal or don't kill a
deal but this routine where you split
the baby is getting very irritating and
repeatedly repeatedly you get this
routine from the from the front from the
Trump administration where they say that
they are going to stand by the they're
going to stand by some conservative
position and they don't do it so the
term administration just brought in 15
they just issued 15,000 new travel visas
for people who are coming in to work for
foreigners they have now announced the
Trump administration has also announced
as
from keeping the Iran deal there's a
couple other things that are that are
skipping that are that I'm missing here
that they've done in the last couple of
days that are not good positive the Cuba
policy for example they said that they
were going to reject Obama's Cuba policy
they've kept most of Obama's Cuba policy
in place again don't pee on our leg and
tell us it's raining okay if you don't
actually want to do anything about
something don't promise you're going to
do it don't make promises you can't
fulfill especially when your entire
shtick is politicians are all dirty
politicians are all liars I'm not one of
them okay other things that I hate in a
Rohrbacher who's a congressman out here
in California other put this in things I
like the things I hate just because it's
so absurd Dana Rohrabacher who I know
and Dana is a nice guy I've spoken at
one of his events and he has like a
drinking beer st. Patty's Day event and
and Dana Rohrabacher I was questioning
someone from NASA yesterday and this is
a thing that actually happened in
America in the Congress the the most
important thing was if Mars
can I ask permission wart for one minute
for this question and that is you have
indicated that Mars had AG was totally
different thousands of years ago is it
possible that there was a civilization
on Mars thousands of years ago so the
evidence is that Mars was different
billions of years ago thousands of years
ago well yes and and there would be
there's no evidence that I'm aware of
that would you rule that out but see
there are some people well anyway I
would it I would say that is extremely
unlikely so that is the thing that
happened a fitting Congress person in
the United States suggested that there
was a civilization on Mars thousands of
years ago because they said that there
was changes on the surface of Mars
billions of years ago so good job Dana
Rohrabacher
he's also known affectionately as
putin's putin's congress person who's
been very very warm for Vladimir Putin
but this is a I think that you may want
to think about qualification if you're
worrying about whether or not there was
civilization on Mars if there is can we
send Congress there in any case okay so
other things that I hate so yesterday
Tucker Carlson who I thought he had to
debate with man
which I refrained from commenting on
because I just didn't see the point I
thought it was quite an awful exchange
of Max food actually I thought the max
boot was largely correct I thought
Tucker was was wildly disingenuous in
the interview I think Tucker's really
good at his job and he's really talented
but I think that he's demagogic and his
approach in in many of these cases he
laughs off any legit criticism of him he
uses he insults his the person that he's
talking to as a preemptory as a
peremptory measure and then he and then
he starts doing me the hysterical laugh
at the end of his show if he if he
doesn't want to talk about something you
know again he has such talents I wish
that he'd put it to better use than
saying that Russia is not in the top
five threats against the United States
in an attempt to kind of mimic tapi
Canon ISM now moving further and further
to the the Paleo con right he had on max
Blumenthal the other night max
Blumenthal is legitimately one of the
scum here people in American politics I
mean just a pig somebody who used to
attack Andrew Breitbart
regularly lie about him max Blumenthal
is in a self-hating Jew he's an ethnic
Jew but he has absolutely nothing to do
with Judaism her book called Goliath
it's been widely panned in which he
repeatedly compares Israel to the Nazis
which is about the most insulting thing
that you can do to both Israel and Jews
generally he is a pig of a and just a
disgusting disgusting radical human
being and Tucker has him on the show why
does he have max Blumenthal on the show
because max Blumenthal agrees there's
nothing to this Trump Russia stuff so
it's very important that you give a
platform it's one of the worst people on
planet earth in order that they can talk
about it
I thought the Democrats should have
responded with a big narrative against
permanent war and for economic equality
instead they're pushing Russia
scandal-mongering non-stop it's assumed
all of the progressive grassroots
grassroots movements I believed in and
it's basically buried the left in a
militaristic narrative that ambitious
figures like Jamie Raskin are advancing
mark my words Tucker when Trump is gone
this narrative this Russia hysteria will
be repurposed by the political
establishment to attack the left and
anyone on the Left Bernie Sanders like
politician who steps out of line on the
issues of permanent war or corporate
free trade things like that will be
painted as a Russia puppet so this is
very
dangerous and people who are progressive
who are falling into it need to know
what the long-term consequences of this
cynical narrative are it seems virtually
everyone on the left in Washington with
some exceptions your one I know a couple
others but I know people who I think it
was reasonable I don't agree with them
but who seemed to really believe that
Vladimir Putin was in control of the
last election do you think they believe
it I don't know I think there's I can't
speak for other people I'm not a
mind-reader but there's definitely a
political app put a political class in
Washington that sees Russia
scandal-mongering as a silver bullet to
take out Trump and then you have the
Democrats who are basically the
Democratic words hungry so eager to get
somebody who is purportedly of left to
turn a perp or leave of the hard left to
talk about why the Trump Russia stuff
isn't the thing that he brings on
somebody like max Blumenthal this is the
same things when sean has on Julian
Assange to talk about how Trump Russia
isn't a thing and then calcium is a hero
though the right is making all sorts of
new friends if your allegiance to a
particular political figure is forcing
you into alignment with people like max
Blumenthal and Julian Assange and you
are now welcoming them as friends and
treating them with with anything but
disdain let me recommend to you that
you've made some mistakes in your life
okay you shouldn't be part of a of a
movement that is now making common cause
with with people like Julian Assange was
put American lives in danger or max
Blumenthal one of the scummiest people
on earth it's amazing I mean remember
Sidney Blumenthal was Hillary Clinton's
hatchet man so we're now at the point
politics is so topsy-turvy and so
circular but at this point Sidney
Blumenthal who used max Blumenthal as an
advisor on Israel to Hillary Clinton is
appearing on Tucker Carlson's show to
defend Donald Trump because Tucker
Carlson wants to defend Rome I mean
that's how crazy all of this has gotten
you know the rules have changed and
there are no rules anymore
it's catch-as-catch-can but you know if
people with principles should think
twice before they start making way for
people like max Blumenthal just cause
he's saying some things you like really
really quite disgusting okay so we'll be
back here tomorrow with all of the
latest on ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
you